Scott's good to have you on the Dan
Patrick show it's Ross Tucker filling in
for Dan today I guess I'm curious much
than anything Scott have you heard
anything new I mean there was new Sunday
about you know this guy that you know
shot will it was in the back have we
heard anything more about motives or
what went down I haven't heard anything
I'm curious as to whether or not somehow
you guys have more information than we
do no we really don't and you know I
think little things keep coming out here
here and there you have different
witnesses stepping forward and they're
trying to put some pieces to the puzzle
together
and you know really really when the
whole story's going to come out is is
when wills wife probably feels up to
talking about that and given everybody
an idea what what actually happened but
you know you spend the day after while
you're grieving and thinking about will
going on social media finally putting a
face to the guy that took his life going
through anger and you find yourself just
going down the path of trying to put
things together and it just got
exhausting it gets really exhausting you
try to put those pieces together but you
know over time it's gonna it's going to
come together but you know I was talking
to Jonathan Vilma yesterday and as many
things we try to piece together the end
result is it doesn't matter I mean will
will still will never be back he'll
never be back with us so we just have to
let the process play out and and try to
cope as best we can you know I think I
have a pretty good sense of the type of
player that will was what kind of person
was he you know in the meeting rooms in
the locker room behind closed doors you
know will was look was one of those guys
who as good a talent as he was on the
field and so many millions of people saw
him on TV and saw how great a football
player he was he was a million times
better person and you know for me to
know him for the last ten years and get
a play seven years with him it was truly
an honor I got to see him away from the
field
how he interacted with everybody on a
day-to-day basis and will was one of
those guys who could just who he could
sit down with anybody for any amount of
time didn't matter where you grew up
what your background was what your
beliefs were what race you were what
religion it didn't matter will will get
along with everybody and if will didn't
get along with you you really had to
look in here as to what you were doing
wrong because there was a reason why
will was voted team captain every year
he was there and he was he was our
anchor he was the guy we turn to in
tough times and he was our leader along
with Jonathan Vilma both guys we
wouldn't accomplish the things we
accomplished without Will Smith and you
know that makes it even harder when when
such a great man away from the football
field was taken when you look at what he
did in the community the things he tried
to do for youth and to have that taken
away you know it's hard and when I knew
yesterday I spent a lot of time doing
interviews and talking about will and
and my phone was blown up with requests
and the initial thing to do I thought
was you know I don't want to talk about
this I want to I want to turn my phone
off but the more I thought about it the
more I thought what better way to pay
tribute and honor a great guy like will
than to talk about what type of guy he
was outside the 91 Jersey that everybody
saw yeah I think that's really well said
it's got we certainly appreciate having
you on Scott of course played a number
of years with Will Smith in New Orleans
you know I see the sack numbers Scott
and I know he went to a Pro Bowl I don't
know why he didn't go to the Pro Bowl in
2009 or wasn't voted into it or whatever
with 13 and a half sacks but looking
back on those Super Bowl teams how
valuable was he on that 2009 Super Bowl
team how important of a piece of the
puzzle was will well I'll say this will
was one of the few holdovers in 2006
when coach paint came in and was
establishing his plan and what he wanted
and will was the perfect perfect guy I
mean he embodied everything we were
trying to get done when you talk about
we wanted tough smart selfless players
who are accountable we'll embodied all
of that and we were fortunate enough to
have our entire group of guy
who embodied that and when you talk
about a team captain and a guy who will
was not a rah-rah guy he was not a jump
around getting your face type of guy but
one will spoke everybody shut up and
listened and and we knew when will spoke
it was coming from the heart and he
meant what he said and he was a leader
by example
you know you you wouldn't find a
hard-working guy a guy I can't remember
recall a guy missing a practice and it
killed him to never be on the field if
he had anything wrong with him injury
wise and you talk about he was a pro's
Pro in the ultimate teammate and
ultimate leader and I really feel like
no matter where he would have got
drafted in the NFL he would have played
as long as he did and been a key
cornerstone to any franchise in the NFL
we're talking with Scott Shanley
longtime teammate of Will Smith here
Scott you know I feel like I should ask
you I'm always curious when guys stop
playing what are you doing now when I
was done I moved back to Dallas I played
here with the Cowboys for a couple years
we really enjoyed the area my wife and
three young kids and settled back here
and you know for a year year and a half
I took time off spent time with my young
kids coached youth football still doing
that but last fall I had an opportunity
to go back to New Orleans and talk
sports television had me come down be
being analyst for the Saints games and
and I really enjoyed it I really enjoyed
going down to Orleans every weekend and
covering a team that I loved and
watching the coaches and the players
that I played with and so I that media
door opened up last fall and I really
enjoyed it enjoy talking about football
you know it's an easy transition for a
lot of us guys who when you sit 10 years
in a meeting room and learn about the
game and when somebody asks you hey what
happened on this play and you can kind
of break it down and and you combine
that with I was covering a team I love
and we want a championship in New
Orleans it was always great going back
down there last fall so hopefully that
continues this year
well hey Scott really appreciate the
time thanks for coming aboard absolutely
thanks for having me on all right there
he is Scott Shanley talking about his
former teammate Will Smith the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you